il y a beaucoup de femmes et de jeunes
filles qui qui jouent peu en en
finalement en multi ou sinon qui se
cache soit avec des pseudon neutres ou
des pseudos plutôt masculins pour éviter
en fait de se retrouver face à des
comportements hyper toxiques
moi j'ai commencé à jouer à cette petite
dans un univers familial pour le coup
c'était assez ouvert et assez libre
là-dessus et donc j'ai d'abord joué sur
de la console et plus tard en tant
qu'adolescente j'ai j'ai fréquenté des
cybercafé et c'est là j'ai découvert un
Counter-Strike donc c'est un jeu de un
jeu de tir à la première personne et ben
c'est à mon adolescence que j'ai
commencé à comprendre en fait les
problématiques liées à la toxicité qui
était coupée avoir en ligne et ouais
donc j'ai j'ai fait face à des remarques
très sexy c'est qui m'ont vraiment
bloqué et qui m'ont censuré sur mon
parcours de joueuse pour le coup jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai plutôt tendance moi je
joue beaucoup mais j'ai quand même
tendance à jouer principalement en solo
ou en local donc avec des gens que je
connais mais j'ai encore cette bah cette
crainte en fait de jouer en ligne en
multi avec des gens que je ne connais
pas
[Musique]
ça va bien nous donne la sphère du jeu
vidéo c'est vraiment l'espace numérique
et la modération qui fait que on se
retrouve à voir ce genre de comportement
donc des remarques sexistes racistes
grossophobes sur des situations de
personnes en situation de handicap des
remarques aussi contre des personnes
LGBT c'est malheureusement des sujets
qu'on retrouve et qui sont difficiles à
vivre au quotidien
[Musique]
l'idée de l'association qui a été créée
par Jennifer lutfos c'était de créer un
espace sain pour une communauté de
joueuse à la base pour se retrouver
raconter un peu ces expériences et jouer
ensemble et petit à petit c'est devenu
une association qui est ouverte à tout
le monde pour le coup et l'idée c'est de
pouvoir travailler sur la représentation
des personnages dans le jeu vidéo de
rôle modèle aussi parce que c'est hyper
important d'avoir des personnes des
personnages qui nous ressemblent mais
que ce soit dans le jeu mais aussi dans
la dans la vie réelle des personnes qui
travaillent dans l'industrie et qui vont
faire naître des vocations
alors on lui dira allez vas-y parce
qu'il faut
en revanche on va l'accompagner on va la
guider et l'idée c'est on travaille
beaucoup sur la modération son
association on s'entraide là-dessus et
d'autres le font aussi et il faut le
faire parce que en fait on avait on a
besoin de visibilité les gens mais ne
pas forcément le faire en lâchant la
personne concernant la nature mais c'est
de la compagnie